[Música]
bom eu fiquei sabendo recentemente que o
destino mais visitado do mundo
atualmente é bancoc capital da tailândia
eu achava que era paris mas paris está
em terceiro lugar mas eu acho que tem um
erro nessa estatística eu acho que o
lugar mais visitado é um lugar que não
apareceu na estatística porque as
pessoas não confessam mas 99% das
pessoas vão lá toda hora e eu mesmo
estive em paris quatro vezes mas eu já
perdi as contas de quantas vezes eu
estive nesse lugar
eu comecei a minha vida o lá eu tinha
uma dificuldade muito grande de me
adaptar ao mundo me sentir em casa no
mundo eu tinha as pernas tortas e finas
eu tinha os dentes tortos eu tinha muito
cabelo ondulado e eu ainda usava um
tênis bamba
ninguém me chamava pra dançar música
lenta na escola e o meu apelido na
escola era amostra grátis
então eu precisava de um psicólogo eu
precisava de um ortodontista eu
precisava de um milagre e eu tinha
apenas umas folhas pautadas e assim eu
comecei a escrever e aí de tanto
escrever eu acabei indo para a faculdade
de comunicação
lá eu tive boas referências estéticas
eu consegui um bom cabeleireiro e também
comecei a gostar de moda
comecei a me vestir bem e mostrar o meu
talento para a moda eo meu talento pra
gastar dinheiro
na verdade eu achava que eu estava nas
nuvens mas eu estava indo de novo pro
fundo do poço e aí com 19 anos
eu cortei os meus cabelos mas com 24
anos a minha mãe faleceu ea mãe teve um
câncer e ficou dois anos doente e nesses
dois anos eu fui pro fundo do poço mas
eu saí desse fundo do poço conhecendo
o pai muito melhor e aí foi um período
muito importante pra mim essa minha
proximidade com o meu pai mas dois anos
cinco anos depois foi meu pai que morreu
meu pai também teve dois anos de câncer
e também faleceu
depois disso eu me casei eu do altar foi
direto para o fundo do poço que não
deveria ter me casado e lá no fundo do
poço a gente mal se entende a gente não
conseguia achar os lugares para onde
queria aí a gente não acertava um
restaurante que a gente queria ir mas
nesse meio tempo eu aparecer um bebê e
eu fiquei muito feliz do fundo do poço
foi direto para as nuvens
fica ali ó lado a lado e quando eu tinha
dois meses de gravidez
eu perdi o bebê e aí dez meses depois a
gente tentou de novo dez meses depois eu
engravidei de novo e perdi de novo eu já
tinha cartão platinum do fundo do poço e
aí no fundo do poço eu entendi que eu
não queria mais está casada eu me
separei um tempo depois eu me apaixonei
de novo e comecei a namorar um namoro
que demorou para começar mais uma paixão
muito grande é um amigo e eu me
apaixonei por um amigo e significa
alguma coisa devastadora porque eu já
amava aquele amigo um ano e meio depois
entre idas e vindas
eu já não pensava mais nisso eu
engravidei e ficamos muito felizes fomos
à tiradentes várias vezes e quando
estava grávida fomos pra ilha grande e
lá a gente passou o reveillon com sete
meses
eu perdi de novo mas dessa vez eu perdi
o marido
o coração dele parou de repente eu me
lembro de dizer pra mim mesma
quanto tempo vai demorar para eu morrer
também
mas aí eu pensei eu não posso morrer em
um bebê dentro de mim e o coração do
francisco bateu por mim por ele durante
dois meses
eu fui pro fundo do poço e eu não queria
estar lá eu não me sentia à vontade nem
no direito de estar no fundo do poço com
o bebê dentro de mim
mas eu resolvi fazer do fundo do poço um
lugar legal eu descobri que lá tem uma
vista linda para o céu
assim como também tem uma vista linda
para o precipício
meus amigos iam me visitar e eu aprendi
muito estive muito perto de mim
nesse período a morte ela é uma grande
em poder a dor porque quando a gente se
depara com a morte
a gente não está diante de um problema
para ser resolvido
a gente não está diante de uma doença
para ser curada
a gente está diante de um fato um fato
que não pode ser mudado
então quando a gente encara a morte só
resta a nós mudar a nós mesmos e é muito
importante que o mundo à nossa volta
continue caminhando é muito importante
que a gente sinta essa solidão porque a
gente precisa encarar o processo do luto
ea gente é que vai elaborar mas se a
gravidez é uma verdade que vai crescendo
diante de nós porque a gravidez
realmente é uma coisa super mágica a
gente pega um exame de gravidez um exame
positivo fica imaginando tem uma bebê
dentro de mim como assim a barriga
demora para crescer
você demora pra acreditar e eu até os 9
meses eu juro eu acreditava que chegaria
no hospital eles vão dizer querido essa
garrafa né não é possível ter um bebê e
tinha a gravidez nessa verdade que vai
crescendo
a morte é uma verdade vestida de absurdo
porque a gente não foi educado para
encarar a morte principalmente uma morte
no auge da vida como um bebê pra nascer
mas eu tinha que encarar aquilo e aí o
luto é uma espécie de gestação porque a
gente vai ter que nascer de novo a gente
morre um pouco pra nascer uma nova
pessoa
e nisso tem um processo que pode nos
ensinar muito
tempos depois o francisco nasceu eu não
quero saber a opinião de vocês a
respeito mas eu achei ele lindo
depois eu posso provar
quando me trouxeram aquele bebê
prontinho para o meu colo depois de um
parto normal super rápido e eu vi que
tinha
todos os itens de série a primeira coisa
que eu falei na sala de parto ea minha
irmã tá aqui ela pode com ela pode
confirmar
foi então é de verdade e aí colocaram
francisco no meu colo chorando e ele
parou de chorar nem o tamanho do poder
que eu tinha mas a vida continuava eu
tinha que encarar esse exercício do
tente outra vez que é o exercício do
luto néon exercício de aprimoramento
humano 71 dias e tenta de novo vai
tentando até que um dia sem perceber se
falou papa
eu consegui eu achava que aquela dor
nunca ia passar mas eu era mãe mais
feliz
eu era a mulher mais triste e aí eu
entendi esse eu não conseguia trazer o
que para francisco eu conseguiria
escrever sobre o que de certa forma
trazer o meu filho e eu comecei a
escrever cartas para o francisco pra
falar do gui para o francisco pra falar
do futuro pra mim mesmo pra falar da
minha dor para o mundo e eu criei um
blog chamado para francisco que se
tornou o meu primeiro livro mas também
tem uma coisa da gestação da posse
gestação que é muito importante a gente
se reconcilia com o nosso corpo depois
que a gente tem um filho a gente precisa
reconhecer esse corpo durante muito
tempo a gente foi 2
então eu olhei para o meu armário cheio
de roupas e comecei a usar esse armário
de uma maneira diferente
eu comecei a enxergar a moda e as roupas
como uma forma de ser muitas mulheres e
comecei a brincar com isso então eu
criei um blog chamado hoje vou assim que
comecei a postar as fotos de toda a
roupa que eu ia trabalhar
foi o primeiro blog de looks do dia do
brasil é fui eu que criei esse monstro e
eu contei para os amigos que eu tinha um
blog chamado hoje vou assim os amigos
devem ter se reunido devem ter pensado a
gente vai ter que consultar um
psiquiatra essa viúva tá louca porque no
blog ela se faz de modelo no outro ela
chora
e não me pergunte onde eu estava com a
cabeça quando eu fiz isso tudo
na verdade eu não estava com a cabeça em
lugar nenhum
mas eu estava com o coração uma vontade
muito grande de me expressar
porque quando a gente está conectado com
nossa cor do nosso coração nome disso é
coragem
a coragem é quando a gente não se
preocupa com o que os outros vão
aumentar
a gente se preocupa com aquilo que a
gente quer fazer e não tem nada mais
poderoso do que é isso o que aconteceu é
que eu descobri que a moda ela pode ser
uma doença ou um remédio dependendo da
maneira como você lida com ela e aí eu
comecei a perceber que me mostrar para
várias mulheres estava transformando
também a vida dessas mulheres
eu estava fazendo uma coisa chamada
empoderamento feminino numa época em que
essa palavra sequer existir e as
mulheres começaram a se sentir melhor
consigo mesmas começaram a se sentir
mais felizes consigo mesmo assim como eu
também estava me sentindo depois escrevi
um livro sobre moda e assim através da
escrita e do vestir eu fui seguindo em
frente e descobriu uma nova profissão eu
saí da agência de publicidade e comecei
a escrever colunas de rádio de revista
hoje eu tô indo pro meu sexto livro me
tornei palestrante consultora de moda e
descobrir quantas mulheres
eu poderia ser a pergunta que me faço é
quem me pariu se foi eu que pariu
francisco ou se foi ele que me pariu
na verdade a gente tem muito medo de ir
pro fundo do poço
muita gente que está no instagram pode
estar dizendo que está em bancoc mas na
verdade tem muita gente ali tirando foto
como estivesse na tailândia mas no fundo
está no fundo do poço
eu mesmo de manhã quando eu olho no
instagram eu vou até o fundo do poço
porque eu percebo o quanto a minha vida
miserável enquanto as pessoas meditam na
praia brincando de argila com os filhos
enquanto desfilam na minha frente às
barrigas negativas e as contas bancárias
positivas
aí eu me lembro que num outro momento eu
também emtu aquela imagem que parece
de sonho quando na verdade muitas vezes
a gente está no fundo do poço
o problema não é ir para o fundo do poço
o problema é ir pro fundo do poço e não
aproveitar a viagem
acham que no fundo do poço não tem
poesia você acha que o chico buarque
quando compôs eu te amo a conta agora
com medo de partir ele estava no alto do
poço não estava no fundo do poço no
fundo do poço a gente tem uma vista
privilegiada para a gente mesmo
é impressionante o quanto a gente
enxerga não tem nenhuma outra situação
em que a gente enxerga tão bem e se
conhece tanto quanto no fundo do poço no
fundo do poço eu pude apurar por exemplo
o meu humor do dia que morreu ele morreu
em casa
eu estava com o carro parado na porta e
muitas pessoas foram chegando os meus
amigos e aí meu amigo me colocou no
carro dele para me levar pra casa e meu
carro ficou ea minha melhor amiga foi
pegar meu carro que era um carro novo ea
minha melhor amiga muito de saída e aí
eu só pedi para o meu amigo um tempinho
fui lá na porta do carro com a minha
amiga foi lida isso é tudo o que me
resta
e assim o humor foi me salvando e acho
que ele é o meu maior mecanismo de
sobrevivência que a gente tem
o fundo do poço na verdade é um conceito
muito particular
em 2007 quando ainda estava lá eu fui
fazer umas compras no shopping em belo
horizonte
e aí a vendedora falou comigo era o
natal ela falou comigo olha você pode
comprar mais coisas pra concorrer a
sorteio do carro eu falei com ela não
posso participar do sorteio do carro
porque eu trabalho na agência de
publicidade que atende o shopping
ela falou então coloca o nome da sua mãe
eu falei morreu ela falou coloca o nome
de seu namorado eu falei morreu também
ela cheia de esperança olhou pra mim e
falou seu pai eu falei morreu todo mundo
e no final eu fiquei consolando a
vendedora
na verdade gente a gente não tem
controle sobre a vida eu mal tem o
controle desse powerpoints o palestrante
várias vezes não funcionou
a vida é não ela não está sob nosso
controle ea gente gasta muito tempo
tentando controlar a grande parte que
não depende de nós e esquece de
controlar a mínima parte que depende de
nós
então se você visitar o fundo do poço o
meu conselho é vá e aproveite
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]